by
a band called Queen once asked who wants
to live forever to which a tiny
gelatinous critter called a Hydra said
me bees this critter may just be
immortal if it loses one of its
tentacles it uses to snag food it'll
grow right back chop a Hydra and - and
you'll get two Hydra take 100 Hydra
break them down into individual cells
and mix those cells together amazingly
the mass will form into a ball and spawn
fully formed Hydra so what can kill a
Hydra well not much short of fire or
getting eaten a scientist once isolated
60 of them in sealed chambers after one
year 2 3 4 years they still looked good
as new that's a suspiciously long time
for such a tiny animal because the
smaller you are typically the shorter
your lifespan but the Hydra seems to
have a cheat it sheds all of its cells
and builds its body from scratch every
couple weeks
it's basically reborn time and time
again and if that isn't inspirational I
don't know what is now somebody cut this
hydron too
you